[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing severus snape
albus dumbledore and the events of the
half-blood prince
more specifically we're going to be
diving into the iconic
and emotional scene where snape ends the
life
of hogwarts lovable headmaster albus
dumbledore
diving in further we're going to be
analyzing snape's murder of dumbledore
and honing in on one peculiar aspect
pertaining to the color of snape's spell
starting all the way at the beginning we
know that dumbledore's death was
preordained
it had to happen and he was going to die
anyway
that's why dumbledore enlisted the help
of snape to kill him
if you don't mind dying said snape
roughly why not let draco do it
that boy's soul is not yet so damaged
said dumbledore
i would not have it ripped apart on my
account as per the rule of the
unbreakable vow that snape had made with
narcissa regarding draco
snape was responsible for taking action
on draco's part
in the event that draco was unable so by
killing dumbledore himself
snape was effectively saving draco and
doing dumbledore a favor
this did however leave snape with the
daunting task
of killing the man that he had grown to
like the man that took him in
after snape defected from the death
eaters when the time comes
and snape is facing dumbledore with his
one doubt at the top of the astronomy
tower
he finally releases the spell that ends
dumbledore
we can very clearly see that snape used
the most effective method of killing
known to the harry potter story avada
kadavra
the killing curse the killing curse is
one of three
unforgivable curses curses that are
unforgivable
because of their sadistic nature avada
kadavra's purpose is simple
it causes the victim to instantly die if
you want to kill your victim
then this is a spell to use the spell
creates a blindingly intense
green bolt of light right before the
victim simply drops dead
but what's curious about snape's
particular avada kadavra
and this is only in the film so take
from it what you will
is that when it strikes dumbledore it
isn't the green
that we're accustomed to it's far more
of a blue
i found significance in this moment
because it's reiterated again and again
that avada kadavra is a green jet of
light so
why was it blue the meanings behind
spell colours in harry potter are never
properly explained
but last week i made a theory video
where i discussed potential
relationships between spell colors
and their meanings in this video i
outline that for a spell to be produced
in its truest form
the spell requires intent and the spell
must be used for the purpose for which
it was made
by this logic someone producing an
expelliarmus properly
and for the right reason would produce a
pure unwavering red colour
from the tip of their wand the same goes
for valikdavra
if used accurately and for the right
reason producing an
unwavering green jet of light so
my theory for snape's blue spell is this
he had regret
in order to produce avada kedavra or any
of the unforgivable curses for that
matter
it requires intent and it's generally
suggested that the degree of intent
will determine how successful the spell
is my thought is that snape had
just enough intent to kill dumbledore
but not enough to produce the spell
in its purest form this would explain
why the spell color wavered
from the traditional green snape didn't
want to kill dumbledore
but he knew that he had to so being the
pragmatic man that he is
he got the task done however that
certainly doesn't mean that he ever
wanted to kill him
it was the last thing that snape wanted
to do he just knew
that it was the right thing to do what
do you guys think of this theory
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
you're a wizard harry
you